[Musik]
halt sie bekommen meine damen und herren
bei 14 8 in den nächsten 5 50 minuten
nehmen wir sie mit auf eine spannende
reise der debatte fünf köpfe werden fünf
meinungen diskutieren das fertig werden
über produktiven streit wollen wir hier
ja auch gar nicht vermeiden meine gäste
heute abbild moderatorin patricia platz
neben ihr bild politik chef jan schäfer
an meiner seite die welt journalistin
susanne gaschke und last but not least
unternehmer und ehemaliger politiker in
nikolaus haufler jeden von uns hier
bewegt ein thema vermutlich kennen sie
das auch zu hause wir lesen etwas den
nachrichten hören etwas im radio und
verspüren den wunsch darüber zu
diskutieren
genauso geht es uns befehl nach 8 und
wir wollen debattieren mein thema heute
abend ist die masken schelte bei kindern
die massen kriegt für die kinder in den
schulen wurde ausgesetzt aber der
emotionale druck steigt und steigt nicht
und die fachredaktion haben eine
vielzahl von briefen nachrichten und
anordnung erreicht und zwar darüber dass
die kinder doch weiter die maske zu
tragen haben lassen sie mich ich habe
ein paar der zuschriften mitgebracht ich
konnte gar nicht alle mitbringen aber
ein paar habe ich mir ausgedruckt lassen
sie mich nur zwei drei sätze daraus
vorlesen dass ihr das hier zum beispiel
ist ein brief den eltern bekommen haben
wo drinsteht von dem direktor
geschrieben so bitten wir sie liebe
eltern mit ihren kindern über das tragen
der masken zu sprechen und sie zum
tragen der maske weiterhin anzuhalten
oder auch ich kann es auch mal rein
zeigen hier sieht man auch so ein
schönes schreiben und dort stand dann
somit werden wir alle auch sie und ihre
familien ein gesundes osterfest feiern
sowie gesunde osterferien verbringen
können auch der elternbeirat unterstützt
diesen appell diesen brief wird also den
kindern eigentlich vermittelt entweder
ihr tragt die maske also auch den eltern
oder ihr habt kann nur des opfers das
letzte möchte ich hier auch gerne noch
mal zeigen auch wieder genau dieser
aufruf ich finde das furchtbar man sich
auch jetzt hier gerade im bilde teppich
eingeblendet bitte freiwillig maske
tragen da staubt von einem berufskolleg
meine meinung ist wir müssen den kindern
die angst wieder nehmen wir müssen
kinder wieder kinder sein lassen und ja
vielleicht sollten wir kinder sogar
lieber dazu animieren dass sie die maske
absetzen dass sie normal mit ihren
freunden umgehen und ich finde oder ich
bitte hier mit inständig jeden direktor
jeden lehrer und jede schule darüber
nachzudenken ob dieser emotionale druck
richtige ist besonders bei den klein und
ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt auf die
meinung von patricia auch kinder hat ja
und ich muss sagen das was mich bei
diesem thema am meisten berührt ist dass
wir eine situation schaffen in der
kinder ausgegrenzt werden können und
zwar zum einen weil sie dennoch eine
maske tragen oder zum anderen weil sie
keine maske tragen und diese situation
möchte ich ehrlich gesagt kinder nicht
aussetzen das heißt wenn wir keine
klaren regeln schaffen schulen im
alleingang für die freiwilligkeit werben
erzeugen wir damit automatisch eine
situation in dem kinder ausgerechnet
kinder in die situation kommen sich
rechtfertigen zu müssen und ich glaube
das ist das schwierigste was wir machen
können ich bin selbst sehr vorsichtig
was corona an gib mir geht selbst sowie
vielen eltern ich möchte nicht dass
meine kinder ist bekommen und es macht
mir auch sorge dennoch nach zwei jahren
pandemie glaube ich dass wir uns und
gerade unseren kindern diese freiheit
wieder schuldig sind wir haben gesehen
dass wir immer nur hören wir steuern in
das nächste und wieder ist kommt wieder
anders als geplant das heißt irgendwann
müssen wir den punkt kommen wo wir nur
noch um ganz allein auf menschlichkeit
untereinander setzen und nicht mehr auf
vorsicht und das müssen wir besonders
bei unseren kindern so machen ja und ich
meine wir sehen ja auch also die politik
war ja nun sozusagen offenkundig hat ja
eingesehen dass die verfassungsmäßig
eigentlich keine möglichkeit hat mehr
die harten maßnahmen weiter
durchzusetzen das heißt sie gibt es
freilich gibt es in die
eigenverantwortung der bürgerinnen und
bürger und der eltern und dann tut es
aber doch wieder nicht und schreibt also
wie der berliner senat sieht
zwar keine masken schlicht mehr gegeben
in der schule sie empfehle aber doch
dringend sagen die masken trotzdem zu
tragen damit trage ich natürlich
wirklich den den bürgerkrieg also in die
schulen hinein und am ende werde ich ein
problem haben dass im moment die ganze
gesellschaft erfasst also dass nämlich
die ängstlichen sozusagen für alle
bestimmen ich verstehe die ängstlichen
gut ich bin auch der meinung so zu sagen
dass man dieses ganze thema
selbstverständlich sehr ernst nehmen
musst aber wir müssen auch sehen dass
die situation sich ändern also wir haben
inzwischen mit varianten zu tun die
jedenfalls bei kindern also in
bruchteilen von prozenten gefährlich
sind und sozusagen die meisten kinder
merken nicht einmal dass sie infiziert
nun könnte man sagen gut wenn die nun
noch wieder mit den großeltern in
kontakt kommen um die großeltern sind
zum teil vier mal jetzt also muss auch
wirklich sagen wir haben doch alles
menschenmögliche getan insofern lasst
die kinder sich doch von mir aus
tatsächlich anstecken und die meisten
die allermeisten werden ist überhaupt
nicht merken dass die normal miteinander
umgehen und
macht nicht weiterhin diesen druck der
ängstlichen denn angst ist ist sozusagen
groß und staat und die wird es ist ja
niemandem benommen sich selbst zu
schützen ich finde auch lehrer müssen
natürlich ist sozusagen dann in der
schule darauf achten dass die dass die
kinder die weiter maske tragen soll weil
die eltern das wollen nicht
diskriminiert geärgert gequält werden
aber das kann man vielleicht hinbekommen
aber das kann man nicht die ganze kinder
gesellschaft die ganze gesellschaft in
haft media sogar noch weiter es gibt
auch schulen die einfach die
selbstverpflichtung verhängen hat sie
hier habe ich auch noch mal einen brief
dass sie alle aus lohnt mit der wurde
also uns auch zu gespielt das steht auch
in verantwortliche haltung und
solidarischer selbstverpflichtungen
werden wir als xx schülerinnen und
schüler die sage jetzt nicht
schülerinnen und kollegium auch ab
montag einem schutzmasken tragen
freiwillige festhalten um uns selbst vor
allem aber die vorerkrankung
schülerinnen und schüler sowie
lehrerinnen und lehrer vorher krank und
infektionen zu schützen sollten die
testung an unserer schule weiterhin
möglich sein wenn auch diese maßnahmen
fortgeführt das war zum beispiel ein
beispiel wo also ist einfach schon
verpflichten von der schule verhängt und
das machen die dann sozusagen als als
solidarischer seit seiner verhaftung
funktion das wurde ja eine art hausrecht
im auge also rein rechtlich dürfen
schulen das jetzt eigentlich gar nicht
komplett verhängen bei privatschulen
weiß ich nicht wir wissen ja aus der
kinderpsychologie oder aus der forschung
das eigentlich ist für kinder zum
aufwachsen und damit sie auch ganz
stabile persönlichkeiten werden es sehr
sehr wichtig ist dass sie vor allem
durch positive erlebnisse gestärkt
werden und bestärkt werden und das
eigentlich das thema angst und zu
anderen gast gerade gesagt eigentlich
genau das falsch ist und ich stelle mir
gerade vor was in vielen haushalten auch
zu hause eigentlich seit zwei jahren los
sein muss beim thema krone und damit
auch beim thema angst wenn solche
maßnahmen ergriffen werden auch wenn
solche briefe von eltern an schulen an
schulleiter geschrieben und geschickt
werden also wie viel angst wird zu hause
dann auch auf kinder projiziert mit
welchen angstgefühlen gehen kinder
möglicherweise oder ganz sicher auch in
die schule in einer zeit in der sie
eigentlich aufblühen sollten und einen
das gefühl bekommen sollten
menschen liebt in gewisser weise die
welt zu füßen und wir wachsen da rein
und wir können auch zum besseren
beitragen und es passiert eigentlich
genau das gegenteil sie werden
eigentlich aus der welt ein stück
herausgerissen und man sagt ihnen alles
draußen ist ganz ganz schlimm und ganz
böse und du musst dich eigentlich in so
ein kokon ja selbst bringen und ich
einig vor der welt verkriechen das
gegenteil dessen was wir ja eigentlich
wollen und das bedrückt mich wenn ich
das auch so sehen was du auch sagt und
was man auch hört und liest dann doch
extrem eine angstkultur die an unseren
schulen einzug genommen hat dies
eigentlich so nach meinem empfinden und
ich mache das man auch schon mehrere
jahrzehnte durch als schüler und auch
als vater noch nicht gegeben hat und wir
haben ja gerade noch mal neue zahlen von
der britischen schule aufsichtsbehörde
offset bekommen die sind einfach
beunruhigend also es ist nicht nur so
dass es eine geschmacksfrage wäre oder
so sondern es schadet auch also zu je
kleiner die kinder sind desto mehr also
verzögert ist offen richtig die
sprachentwicklung ist wird daher oft
hier noch auf mimik gelernt und und das
muss man ein ganzes gesicht sehen und
die haben also relativ erschreckende das
sind also qualitative studien
offensichtlich also verschiedene
institutionen aber gründlich befragt und
stellen einfach fest es gibt große
probleme ich weiß nicht wie das ich
glaube der ethikrat sieht das inzwischen
auch etwas kritischer wir sind da noch
am anfang der der aufarbeitung aber es
gehört kommen mir das ist ja meine
gehackt es keine geschmacksfrage es hat
auswirkungen auf die kleinen menschen
ich finde diese studie auch ganz ganz
wichtig man darf ja nicht immer nur von
ryan emotionen her gehen für masten oder
gegen machten sondern sich die wirkung
auf dem jungen leute anschauen ich kann
mir das überhaupt nicht vorstellen als
so junger mensch mit so einer ausnahme
situation konfrontiert zu sein kann mich
doch nicht rein versetzen dem kinder
aber dieses das gegenüber nicht sehen
nicht verstehen lächelt er gerade ist
traurig ist er wütend muss eine ganz
merkwürdige situation sein für die die
das nicht so erahnen können weil sie ja
noch nicht so lange diese sozialen
interaktionen eingeübt haben deshalb
sollte man wirklich solche studien
besonders ernst nehmen und immer stärker
in die debatte einbringen um auf solchen
zahlen grund laden zu orientieren ich
sehe dass selbst bei mir ich habe drei
kinder und zwei davon sind eigentlich in
die mit der pandemie aufgewachsen im
sinne ist drei jahre alt und wenn man
die zwillingsmädchen einkaufen spielen
dann holen die sich eine mache und
ziehen eine maske auf um dann so zu tun
als würden sie einkaufen gehen und das
war auf der einen seite süß und auf der
anderen seite hat mich natürlich total
erschreckt weil ich dachte ja natürlich
ihr kennt gar nicht mehr einkaufen
spielen ohne die maske vor dem gesicht
und ich habe mich auch gefragt was macht
es mit diesen kindern wie bringe ich die
überhaupt an den punkt zu sagen das
machen wir jetzt aber gar nicht mehr das
braucht ihr gar nicht mehr weil das
natürlich bei kleinen dreijährigen schon
so tief drinnen steckt sie kennen es
einfach mich sie waren noch babys als
wenn auch ohne maske eingriffen gegangen
sind und ich glaube auch unterschiedlich
total zu dass all diese wirkungen die
jetzt völlig noch unabsehbar sind die
wir überhaupt noch nicht fassen können
dass wir uns damit ganz intensiv werden
beschäftigen müssen was machen wir mit
den kindern die angst haben die angst
haben von der zukunft die angst haben
dass wir es unvorhersehbare es kommt und
ich erzähler meine kinder sehr real und
versuche das auch ich will ihnen weder
angst und panik machen noch will ich sie
in bullerbü aufwachsen sehen weil so die
welt nicht ist ich möchte dass wir uns
damit auseinandersetzen und ich glaube
dass das ganz große thema jetzt sein
wird in den nächsten monaten und jahren
wer weiß wie lange diese pandemie uns
auf die eine oder andere art und weise
noch begleitet aber dass wir da unseren
fokus drauf setzen ich bin ja froh dass
die schulen auf haben deswegen bin ich
wahrscheinlich bei der masse wird immer
denke bevor die schulen wieder zu machen
und man die ganzen kinder wieder völlig
aus nimmt aus diesem gesamten system und
das ging so überraschender muss schnell
das nicht als totalen tiefpunkt sei also
lud er aber steht das als mutter aber
ich bin der sagt okay das also ich finde
auch nicht mit aber das hätte ich
niemals passieren die massen aber
dennoch falsch und wir können auch jetzt
nicht einen fehler mit dem nächsten jahr
gut mag ich finde es ehrlich wen
schlechter albtraum inhalt noch im
hinterkopf hat und ich denke diese
entscheidung haben wir so leichtfertig
jahre schnell geht ja und bei diesen
briefen steckt auch total hinter dieses
das kind muss die angst vor spüren dass
es andere krank macht das finde ich
eigentlich das schlimmste dass möglichst
wenige anstrengungen der letzten woche
vor den osterferien auftreten das heißt
jetzt sollen eigentlich wieder
showmaster damit das lehrpersonal bloß
in die osterferien fahren wir haben die
haben ungeimpfte kinder vorgeführt vor
der klasse sozusagen die dann vor der
klasse getestet wurden also sozusagen es
scheint um das die pädagogische begabung
im land durchaus unterschiede besteht zu
sein also manche und auch um das
engagement ehrlich gesagt und wir wollen
nicht vergessen dass gerade die
lehrerverbände also immer sehr dafür
waren ganz wahnsinnig vorsichtig zu sein
während glaube ich alle eltern oder die
meisten eltern die es überhaupt
interessiert beobachten konnten das auch
der distanz unterricht für die kinder
nicht besonders gut und nicht besonders
einfach war das heißt also wer sehr
engagierte lehrer hat hat er glück aber
es gibt offensichtlich leute die also
auch gar keinen begriff von
pluralistischer demokratische schule
haben da muss ich aber einmal auch
nochmal manchen eltern etwas sagen also
ich finde das interessiert man glaube
ich auf jedem elternabend auch sieht man
wie emotional und wir in
unterschiedlichen lagern man sich
befinden kann überhaupt unter der
elternschaft und ich finde es schon auch
wahnsinn wie viele eltern zu meiner
beobachtungen auf jeden fall ist noch
gibt die einer serie cupid strategie
festhalten und die für ein so genannten
durchsuchungen die allergrößte panik
haben ich habe eingangs gesagt mir macht
das auch sorge ich möchte nicht dass
meine kinder corona bekommen dennoch ist
mir das wohl meiner kinder und die
menschlichkeit untereinander gerade
jetzt nach zwei jahren pandemie wo wir
ganz klar sehen wir können uns da nicht
in einen panzer abdichten und noch mit
sinn so das wird uns alle in irgendeiner
form berühren oder es hat uns schon
berührt ist mir das wichtiger geworden
und ich wundere mich schon darüber wie
viele eltern ist noch gibt die da
wirklich eine ganz ganz extreme position
vertrete für eine extreme angst hier für
herrn die fehler der gemacht wurde war
ja dass in den ganzen runden es gab beim
kurz bevor es dann ein bund länder
gipfel gab also bei der bundeskanzlerin
eigentlich ganz ganz viele biologen und
physiker die irgendwelche modelle
modelliert haben gehört wurden was
sicherlich auch sinnvoll war und ist
aber was fehlte waren beispielsweise
kinderärzte oder
jugendpsychiater psychologen die
eigentlich dann aus der praxis hätten
berichten können was macht das
eigentlich mit unseren kindern wenn wir
da an die wohlhabenden gruppen
beispielsweise die senioren denken dann
ist das absolut richtig aber was macht
das eigentlich mit unseren kindern wenn
wir denen sagen und jetzt bleibt ihr
immer schön drei monate zu hause und
setzt euch an euren computer oder das
thema maske ist natürlich 1 englisch zu
lernen bei einer lehrerin bei einem
lehrer bei dem man den mund nicht sehen
kann stell ich mir relativ schwierig vor
gerade wenn es um das stage
beispielsweise geht also da hat man die
bedürfnisse und belange der kinder
leider gottes über fast anderthalb jahre
komplett ausgeblendet und das ist echt
eine tragödie die ist glaube ich auf
jeden fall aufzuarbeiten gilt leider
sind gewisse verantwortliche personen
dafür nicht mehr in amt und würden viel
kann man auch sagen zum glück nicht mehr
aber wenn es um verantwortung in dem
fall geht dann wäre es glaube ich gut
wenn auch die bundeskanzlerin sich dazu
irgendwann noch mal äußern würde die
ehemalige bundeskanzler muss ich ja
sagen sie ist ja nicht mehr man wie
könnte frau merkel sich denn dazu äußern
oder wie könnte sie sich vielleicht auch
entschuldigen und witziges überhaupt zu
sehen nein sie alles was man gehört hat
aus berlin du weißt es besser als ich
stand sehr sehr hinter diesem maß also
es gibt ja ärzte die gesagt haben die
waren ja auch bei bild live und die
gesagt haben es wär mal toll wenn wir
nicht nur theoretiker in den runden bei
der kanzlerin hätten sondern wenn dir
auch mal praktiker dort hätten und ich
glaube dass etwas was total gefehlt hat
und da mache ich eigentlich jemandem der
in so einem pandemie startet überhaupt
kein vorwurf aber diese pandemie hat ja
nun länger gedauert und die kritik daran
wurde ja auch lauter und hörbarer und
dann fragt man sich doch warum
eigentlich dann gewisse gewisse ärzte
oder mediziner gruppen eigentlich in
diesen runden nie dabei waren sondern
warum angela merkel eigentlich immer auf
ihre alt bewährtes personal ich
kommunist mal so flapsig gesetzt hat und
nie gesagt hat mensch es gibt ja noch
andere berufsgruppen oder auch andere
gesellschaftsgruppen das ist eigentlich
mit denen wie hören wir die eigentlichen
also dass wählte total es gab
stellungnahmen also einer großen zahl
von von kinderärztlichen fachverbänden
die aber immer irgendwo im nirwana
letzten endes mehr oder weniger gehört
verhalten wenn sie glück hatten kamen
sie in manchen medien vor in vielen auch
nicht
und ich finde diese frage der
aufarbeitung auch hochinteressant es
stehen ja im raum der vorschlag zum
beispiel eine enquetekommission zu
machen zu corona und ich finde dass
dringend nötig weil ich finde dass das
parlament auch sozusagen seine eigene
rolle noch mal sehr selbstkritisch
ansehen muss das hat praktisch die
verantwortung komplett an der tür
abgegeben komplett an die exekutive
abgegeben und gesagt wir unterwerfen uns
den wir tun nicht mal mehr so als ob wir
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite verantwortungsvoll diskutieren
sondern das kann frau kanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten entscheiden und
natürlich könnte eine enquetekommission
auch noch mal fragen an die ehemalige
kanzlerin formulieren ich fürchte nur
auch da ist nicht viel einsicht ich
finde das hat ideologische züge geradezu
angenommen also dieses team vorsicht
glaubte wirklich im besitz einer höheren
wahrheit und das wurde verteidigt wie
also in den anderen jahrzehnten der
marxismus das war ja auch eine
wissenschaftliche wahrheit und da war
einfach schwer dagegen also dazwischen
zu kommen aber jetzt mit etwas mehr ruhe
ohne zorn aber mit einem kritischen
rückblick wäre es vielleicht besser
möglich muss jetzt zugeben ich bin ein
bisschen zornig auf die zurückliegenden
jahre aber er hat uns auch ein thema
mitgebracht hast du diesen komplex passt
es schließt ein bisschen anderen das was
wir gerade jetzt diskutiert haben und es
geht um den ethikrat speziell um die
chefin ali netbooks und die hat sich
geäußert jetzt gesagt dass gerade im
rückblick und wir habe gerade über das
thema kinder und schulen gesprochen doch
einiges in der pandemie nicht richtig
gelaufen ist in meinen worten hat sie so
ungefähr ausgedrückt dass man doch sagen
muss da gab es viele fehler das ist
bemerkenswert denn wir wissen dass der
ethikrat gerade im jahr 2020 aber auch
im vergangenen jahr in der pandemie eine
wahnsinnig tragende rolle hat wenn nicht
sogar eine der tragenden rollen wenn es
um empfehlungen gerade an die
bundeskanzlerin ging und ich möchte
erinnern beispielsweise an das jahr 2020
vielleicht erinnern sie sich auch noch
an die sogenannte ein kind rege oder ein
freund regel die es dann mal geben
sollte also kinder sollten sich nur noch
mit einem freund treffen dürfen mit dem
gleichen freund da hat der ethikrat
gesagt eigentlich eine ganz gute idee
haben wir auch machen dann ging es um
die frage lockerung an schulen im
vergangenen herbst da hat der ethikrat
in form von frau brooke gesagt nein das
wäre der falsche weg und jetzt plötzlich
wo wir ja den freiheitstag man mag ihn
beschreiben will hinter uns haben oder
erlangt haben wo wir sehen das auch in
gewisser weise das thema corona etwas
ist was uns nicht mehr ganz so stark
belastet wie noch vor einigen monaten da
kommt der ethikrat auch in form von frau
brooke auf die idee zu sagen also es ist
doch vieles falsch gelaufen
vergangenheit ich finde das ist eine
wende helligkeit nicht zu überbieten das
ist eine billige masche das ist quasi
haltet den dieb frau brooke will sich da
offenbar auch dann und wir sprachen
gerade über die antwort kommission
freimachen von schuld aber so einfach
wird auch das nicht sein deswegen ich
fordere auch ganz klar wir müssen das
dringend im bundestag aufarbeiten und da
wird auch eine kritische
auseinandersetzung des ethikrates mit
dazu
ethische fragen sind ja immer fragen von
abwägung ist es ja nie etwas komplett
richtig oder komplett falsch und die
frage ist hat der ethikrat eigentlich
ethisch gehandelt denn in dieser zeit in
der die abwägung notwendig war waren war
er hat diese abwägung nicht
stattgefunden jetzt wird sie nachgeholt
und das ist für mich ein eingeständnis
dass die arbeit nicht ordentlich gemacht
worden ist dass man eben nicht diese
abwägung gemacht hat welche positiven
dinge haben einschränkungen aber auch
welche negativen wirkungen haben die un
jetzt die negativen auswirkungen im
nachhinein nachzuschieben ist
tatsächlich der versuch die
verantwortung die man damals hatte
zumindest auch in der öffentlichen
debatte nach motto wir sind als ethikrat
dafür was in der politik beschlossen
wird diese verantwortung ein wenig von
sich zu weisen das ist so schwierig und
wir müssen uns wirklich überlegen ob man
einen solchen ethikrat braucht der dann
erst im nachgang feststellt was es
eigentlich alles noch hätte abzuwägen
gegeben naja ich bin ja schon fast froh
also ich bin so milde gestimmt heute ich
war ja gut aber ich bin ja schon froh
wenn leute wenigstens im nachhinein
einsehen dass da irgendwas problematisch
gewesen ist also ich glaube der prozess
der aufarbeitung sind zwei wirklich
schwierige jahre gewesen wir haben uns
letzten endes als als ganzes
demokratisches land orientiert am
chinesischen paradigma wir haben jetzt
noch mal nach shanghai guckt der sieht
jetzt mit der distanz na das ist ja wohl
keine demokratische lösung so kann man
doch nicht mit offenen gesellschaften
umgehen haben aber fast so gemacht und
leute haben das gerechtfertigt und viele
haben das mitgemacht auch in unserem
beruf staat muss man sagen und das wird
dauern also bis das sozusagen dann
systematisch und sauber aufgearbeitet
ist und man ja auch schuld zuweisen kann
das wird man müssen aber eben auch vor
einigen sagen kann was hat denn jetzt
wie gewirkt ich mache ja auch schön wenn
wir vielleicht für eine künftige fälle
das wird möglicherweise ja nicht die
letzte pandemie gewesen sein vielleicht
war das auch nicht die gefährlichste die
jemals kommen wird also wenn wir jetzt
mal was draus lernen könnten wäre es ja
ganz schön und dafür ist prinzip ganz
wichtig finde ich was der ethikrat jetzt
in diesem in diesem 180 grad papier dann
doch auch sagt nämlich dass wir ganz
viele zahlen gar nicht haben dass also
zwei gesundheitsminister bisher offenbar
also nie so genau wissen wollten wer auf
den intensivstationen eigentlich liegt
also sind die nun geimpft oder nicht
gewusst wie oft geimpft worden die sich
angesteckt sind die alten oder jungen
die sind natürlich überwiegend haben
einen migrationshintergrund und haben
die japan oder mit kronen an oder im
spiel sind immer wieder an oerlikon aber
mit den 200 toten im moment die die
täglich gezählt werden die sterben ja
nicht an dem tag die werden an dem tag
jeweils gezählt wird ja immer noch
politik gemacht im sinne von das ist
viel zu viel und das geht gar nicht die
leute haben kurzes gedächtnis im
vergangenen jahr auf der höhe der
zweiten welle hat mir tausend tote am
tag da wird hört zu sagen dass über die
normale sterbliche einer ganz anderen
dissidenz immer noch ihren auf die
inzidenz schauen würde eine um ein mehr
als das zehnfache niedrigere incident
absolut also insofern ich bin wenigstens
froh dass sie den schritt gehen nicht
darauf zu beharren daten ja ich war sein
und sagen warum ich habe mich ja impfen
lassen und war bin auch darmstadt und
das alles das heißt ich habe ja gar
nicht diese gesellschaftliche aus also
ich würde ja nicht rausgeschmissen aus
der gesellschaft weil ich war ja die
gute geimpfte aber es gab wirklich
menschen wurde rausgeschmissen und ich
war bei einer bei einer lesung vor zehn
tagen und das beispiel wird jetzt jede
mechanische erstmal merkwürdig vorkommt
kam es mir auch erst dann sagen sie mir
zukommt wie furchtbar und da hat mir
eine dame erzählt die hat sich mir
vorgestellt dass sie auch gern mal
abschalten und dass sie sich nicht
impfen lassen und wollte mir von ihren
erfahrungen in den winter erzählen und
dann ist er sie konnte damit wohl gut
umgehen und dann stand sie irgendwann
mal vom geschäft was leer war und wollte
sich ohrringen kaufen deswegen ich sage
alle empfinden das jetzt als
oberflächliches beispiel und dann durfte
sie sich diese ohrring ja nicht kaufen
weil sie das geschäft nicht betreten
durfte was leer war aber nicht mit maske
und dann ist sie wohl bitterlich in
tränen ausgebrochen und erst habe ich
gedacht oh ringer zu kaufen da gibt es
auch schlimmeres aber dann einen sich im
zug saß habe ich gedacht wie wahnsinnig
dass wir menschen die steuern zahlen die
für unser land arbeiten die mitglieder
der gesellschaft sind nicht erlauben in
einen leeren laden reinzugehen und
ohrringen zu kaufen und ehrlich gesagt
ich habe das beispiel ist auch extra
erzählt zu zeigen ich nehme das ernst
und diese ohrringe geschichte nämlich
auch ernst und deswegen möchte ich dass
diese frau sich nicht nur
korrigiert ich weiß nicht was sie machen
sollen bei diesem zitat aber auf jeden
fall mehr als das ich bin irgendwie
voreingenommen weil ich möchte ganz
kurzen mehr sagen weil du hast so groß
den hammer rausgeholt ich finde alena
wirkt einfach nach hamm ab ohne frau und
deswegen bin ich so ein bisschen hauer
all genommen so manchmal ist man also
ein bisschen so ich finde wenn sie in
der bundespressekonferenz saß hat sie
sehr klar argumentiert sie hat sehr klar
dass dargelegt und ich tendiere auch
mehr dazu zu sagen jetzt geht man in der
korrektur hoffentlich lernen wir daraus
hoffentlich nehmen wir uns ich meine man
hört natürlich auch immer und das ist
natürlich auch ein satz den können wir
alle schon gar nicht mehr hören in
dieser pandemie jemand musste zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch nicht was man jetzt weiß
so das ist ja immer das argument dann
wird könnte man wieder alles aushebeln
wir wussten damals noch nicht was ist
deswegen haben wir so entschieden und
ich glaube dass wir davon ist man
langsam so ein bisschen wegkommen ich
hoffe dass das dafür auch ein anstoß ist
dass man nicht nur sagt wir hatten
damals nicht die informationen sondern
dass man sagt gut werden dass damit so
entschieden jetzt könnte alles anders
kommen aber das sind die statute das
sind die dinge die wir hochhalten die
uns wichtig sind an denen wir uns in der
zukunft entlanghangeln wollen und wenn
wir alle einsehen würden und das führt
auch zu unserer vorhergegangenen
diskussion zurück dass kinderrechte
einfach so brutal missachtet wurden dass
wir mal einsehen dass kinder noch immer
glaube ich glaube wir haben erstaunlich
wenig daraus gelernt noch immer nicht
die bedeutung in unserer gesellschaft
bekommen die sie verdienen die sie
brauchen die wir brauchen auch um unsere
gesellschaft dementsprechend zu
verändern dann muss ich sagen dann ist
es eine bankrotterklärung mich nur für
den ethikrat sondern für uns alle und
ich hoffe einfach vielleicht will ich
auch milde gestimmt heute oder aline
bicks voreingenommen kann man
unterstellen aber ich hoffe dass daraus
das resultiert dass wir dahin kommen und
deswegen bin ich für jedes fehler ein
geständnis denn wo kommen wir hin wenn
man viele eingestellt und dann ärgern
wiederum darüber dass man es eingestellt
am ende erkennt keiner mehr einen fehler
ein und wir kommen überhaupt nicht mehr
über das tolle ist ja an uns menschen
glaube ich auch dass wir jemanden
sympathisch finden können müsst ihr
nicht der gleichen meinung sein und dann
gucken vertrocknen ganz zivilisiert auch
milde gestimmt ich aus fragen also aber
eine frau sache so tolle frau oder ein
mann sagte hammermann oder
und trotzdem nicht einer meinung ist das
ja super dass ereignet glaube ich den
menschen die auch wenn sich am ende oder
daraufhin mit besonders led bis auf
besonnen sie gesprochen musste sich
jetzt sie fahren eine seltenheit
manchmal martin korrigieren und hat
offenbar selbst festgestellt gewisse
dinge die sie gesagt hat war nicht
richtig meine große sorge ist eigentlich
wir hatten klima corona jetzt habe den
krieg dass wir über den krieg und das
was jetzt passiert schon wieder auch so
atemlos sind dass wir das was war
nämlich kona und die lehren daraus und
die folgen und das das ganze
missmanagement das ist ja auch gegeben
hat gar nicht richtig auf arbeiten
können
das link bleibt das ist wie bei der cdu
die ja immer sagt jan machen wahlkampf
aufbereitungen hat aber nicht
stattgefunden und angela merkel
hat die große befürchtung habe ich
eigentlich es gibt hier noch nach dass
wir gar nicht dazu kommen können weil
wir jetzt schon wieder so auf krieg
gepostet und alles was da kommt daher
auch feststellen müssen wie viele
nachlässigkeiten in den letzten
jahrzehnten gegeben hat auch noch nach
und irgendwann kommt der sap anime und
wir stehen da mehr oder weniger beim
thema flüchtlinge ja auch nicht viel
anders aus 215 wenn man mal guckt die
technisch gerade flüchtlinge registriert
oder eben nicht registriert wenn wir das
oft wieder noch mit zettel und stift
geht da muss man ist meine befürchtung
wir gehen unvorbereiteten das nächste
drama was sich da ankündigt
möglicherweise ja sicher die völker
liebt ja wo ich teile meine frage des
das besondere ist ja heute hier sitzen
ja außer mir drei journalisten
und es gibt ja noch ein anderes thema
was die bevölkerung sehr bewegt und zwar
nicht nur das versagen des ethikrates
sondern auch das versagen des deutschen
journalismus ich würde das jetzt nicht
als versagen beschreiben aber es wurde
jetzt auch festgestellt dass
in der pandemie die berichterstattung zu
einseitig war und auch da werden der
sachen aufarbeiten müssen was den
journalismus betrifft die frage ist und
das ist meine frage an die runde die
frage ist für mich ganz klar wie können
wir denn in der zukunft verhindern dass
meinungen im diskurs gecancelt werden
weil hast du gesagt hast patricia wir
wussten ja nichts wenn man sagen das war
vorher ich kann mich an einige menschen
erinnern und darunter gab es auch
biologen und journalisten andere die
schon vor anderthalb jahren
probiert haben zu kämpfen dass es wäre
anders vorgehen und ich kann am
schwierigsten das meinungen so
eigentlich ausgeschlossen wurden oder
abweichende meinungen werden mundtot
gemacht hat ja auch schon gast gesagt
wie wir da vielleicht vorgehen können in
zukunft das die meinungspluralität
wieder größer ist auch im journalismus
also ich glaube wir müssen zu einer ganz
anderen art von institutionalisierter
also in den einzelnen medien verankerter
medienkritik kommen es ist ja ein
bisschen schwierig ich glaube das ist ja
nun kein geheimnis dass wir hier glaube
ich alle in der runde springer
journalisten sind und ich glaube beide
häuser welt und bild haben sich nicht so
wahnsinnig viel vorzuwerfen ist eine von
das meiner meinung gar nicht vorgekommen
werden und es ist auch nicht zu
bestreiten dass bei uns häufig kritik an
den öffentlich rechtlichen medien
vorkommt ich finde häufig mit guten
argumenten aber insofern gibt es
natürlich eine frontstellung und und
öffentlich-rechtliche journalisten ich
saßen deutlich auf einem podium die
fühlen sich dann auch sehr leicht
angegriffen sind dann auch sauer also da
gibt es sozusagen auch eine alle häuser
konkurrenz oder oder wie man das nennen
soll das muss alles weg das ist dass das
bringt uns überhaupt nicht weiter
sondern ich glaube wir müssen versuchen
wieder eine kultur zu etablieren wo man
sich den einzelnen beitrag und den
einzelnen text vornimmt und sagt so da
ist aber folgende frage gar nicht
gestellt da ist sozusagen da kommt die
gegenseite ja gar nicht zu wort und da
sind sozusagen möglicherweise auch
falsche behauptungen drin und wir haben
das bei diesem konzept der frosch
balances wurde dann bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen irgendwann
eingeführt also am anfang haben sie ja
manchmal noch versucht also mehrere
meinungen zu bringen auch wenn immer
klar war dass das team vor sich da
ziemlich am ruder war irgendwann hörte
dass dann auch auf dann hatte man sehr
gleichförmige sendung wo alle der
meinung waren es ganz gefährlich aber
wenn ich das jetzt hier so sagen kann
das schon wieder wie polemik wirken von
jemand von der welt und ich glaube wir
müssen einfach an journalisten werden
natürlich auch nicht gerne kritisiert
ist keiner von uns mag das und und sind
manchmal empfindlicher also als als sie
sein sollten wenn man denkt wie sehr sie
andere leute kritisieren aber
wenn wir das etwas professioneller
wieder hinbekommen würden dass man
wirklich sich die beiträge auch mal
anguckt und sagt also nichts gegen den
kollegen sehen die kolleginnen aber dass
da habt ihr einfach was auf gelassen
dass das ist so kein rundes bild das
stimmt so nicht oder das ist eine also
bloß artig zugespitzt und wenn wir uns
daran wieder ein bisschen mehr gewöhnen
würden glaube ich aber das wird auch ein
prozess der drei jahre dauert glaube ich
dass man dass man versucht also
gegenseitige medienkritik ohne ohne
diese häuser konkurrenz fan ist das
haben sie den eindruck uns ist es ein
bisschen auch abhanden gekommen und ich
frage mich woran das liegt so woran
liegt es dass wir uns auch alle selbst
in die pflicht nehmen müssen zu sagen
lasst uns diesen beitrag noch einmal
anschauen lasst uns diesen text noch
einmal anschauen also wir alle sind
vielleicht aufgewachsen in einem
journalismus weil wir gesagt haben es
ist doch klar dass all diese fragen
beantwortet werden müssen es ist klar
dass wir das prüfen es ist klar dass wir
die gegenseite abholen und uns das
anhören damit dieser artikel dieser
beitrag rund ist ich stelle mir oft
selbst die frage wann und ich habe ich
teil ihren eindruck und auch den
vorschlag dass wir da wieder hinkommen
müssen aber wann oder auch vor allem
warum droht das manchmal hinten
runterzufallen
also es ist eine komplizierte erklärung
ich bin mir auch nicht sicher ob sie ob
sie richtig ist denn uns wird man ja
immer noch ein bisschen vorwerfen also
springer am weitesten sinne wie rechte
oder konservative medien zu sein das ist
das was man hört also ich hoffe ich
beleidige da niemanden aber das ist das
was man im bekanntenkreis gesagt bekommt
während ich also sozusagen aus der
innenperspektive das als relativ
pluralistisch wahrnehmen also bei der
welt haben wir unendliche diskussionen
darüber was jetzt der richtige standort
ist und ich finde auch alle diese
diskussionen im blatt wieder und in der
zeitung sozusagen die ist so übermäßig
natürlich eine etwas andere zeitung aber
da kommt es mir auch so vor
aber lassen wir das mal dahin gestellt
als kann sogar sein dass wir noch so
eine art weltanschauliche identität
haben aber ich glaube insgesamt ist die
dem journalismus sehr abhanden gekommen
also es sollte kein links und rechts im
journalismus mehr geben parteilich war
auf einmal laut und man wurde
überparteilich mann wurde zum
schiedsrichter also würde sagen sie vor
20 jahren hat das allerdings scheinen ja
aber schiedsrichter weiß ich gar nicht
habe manchmal fast den eindruck gehabt
auch zum sprachrohr also zum zweiten
oder dritten regierungssprecher und das
war ja eigentlich das was am ende in der
pandemie ein zunehmendes problem war bei
dem ein oder anderen unserer geschätzten
kollegen zu sagen ja wenn es die
bundeskanzlerin doch gesagt hat da muss
das doch so sein und wenn das der
virologe xy so gesagt generell muss das
doch so hans druckt iva schon und dann
verstärkte man das eigentlich noch und
hat die arbeit von steffen seibert
gemacht das ist glaube ich ein
kernproblem dass wir erlebt haben und
das hat sich irgendwie extrem zugespitzt
über die vergangenen anderthalb bis zwei
jahren und da stand quasi dann der
regierungssprecher eines mediums gegen
den journalisten eines anderen mediums
und hat sich natürlich verteidigt ist ja
auch die aufgabe eines
regierungssprechers er ist aber oder sie
eben kein regierungssprecher gewesen
sondern eigentlich ein journalist und da
glaube ich hat man den clash dann am
besten ja oder am stärksten gemerkt
krone war ja auch nicht das dankbarste
thema wahrscheinlich für viele kollegen
wenn ich das neues außenstehender sagen
darf weil er sehr zahlen getriebenes
thema war bei der welt wurden ja sogar
ein kollege aus der wirtschaftsredaktion
für die ganzen corona zahlen abgestellt
und hat die fleißig täglich bei twitter
eingestellt hat denn so interessiert war
einer der wenigen glaube ich der diese
zahlen wirklich begriffen hat ich habe
das selbst bemerkt dass viele zahlen
völlig falsch gedeutet wurden selbst von
menschen die naturwissenschaften
studiert haben um dort in diesen zahlen
wust von grone herauszugreifen was ist
wirklich bedeutend was hat wirklich
einen einfluss was hat kein einfluss
hätte glaube ich mathematik kenntnisse
erfordert die nicht so super verbreitet
waren im journalismus das war so ein
bisschen ungünstiges thema für viele das
kann aber eigentlich auch nur ein
anderer aufrufe aldi wie vielleicht
junge zuschauer die dame auf viele junge
zuschauer die vielleicht journalisten
werden wollen ich glaube es lohnt sich
in unserem beruf zeigt jetzt vielleicht
auch noch mehr auf eine spezialisierung
zu setzen also ich glaube dass wir alle
ich bin groß geworden als journalist
unter hieß es du musst überall bescheid
wissen muss sich in jedem thema
auskennen das ist sicherlich nicht
verkehrt im journalismus ich glaube aber
dass wir zunehmend auch menschen
brauchen die sich ganz spezifisch dann
in einer sache besonders gut auskennen
die wattener entweder rein das bringt
auch eine pandemie mit sich dass man
plötzlich der zahlen verstehe ist obwohl
man aus der wirtschaft kommt oder so
aber ich glaube dass das auch tun
ja und gesundheit sonst wird er
natürlich noch von zahlen der kollege in
der schau der uns zu wahrscheinlich ja
ja aber dass man plötzlich im
gesundheits feld derjenige der sich
total auskennt und ich glaube dass das
etwas ist worauf man auch zunehmend
setzen kann wenn man leute einstellen
oder wenn wir junge journalisten sehen
dass man sagt wir brauchen eigentlich
wirklich fach menschen auch mehr das ist
doch ein schöner appel und mit diesem
appell und auch dieser selbstkritik was
journalisten eigentlich nicht so gerne
machen geben wir jetzt ab in eine ganz
kurze unterbrechungen sind gleich mit
zwei weiteren spannenden themen für sie
da bist gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich ein lauter krach und
nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zurück viertel nach acht
gegentoren der schlagend sein machen
mein name ist relativ
so nicht
herr jörges retten
aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der damen führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russ und die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der
afg zu überlassen lasst den leuten noch
mal den spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu finden
und sie sollen den doch auch wichtig
dass
auch das übrige anorak träger aus in
bewegung bringen ich habe meinen beifall
um eine sache immer bekommt wer kümmert
sich darum niemand ist
auch darüber sprechen dass man nicht
wirklich richtig ist ich konnte medien
nicht mehr glauben nur noch 4 verloren
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauer
zurück bei für den a8 wir freuen uns sie
dran geblieben sind und wir schalten
jetzt einmal zu meinem kollegen paul
ronzheimer in die ukraine nach kiew ich
hoffe es schon da bislang höre ich ihn
noch nie da ist er ja paula es dauert ja
doch danach ein wenig du bist einer der
letzten journalist live in der ukraine
und berichtet paul wir damals unsere
firma acht zuschauern auch versprochen
dass wir dranbleiben und deswegen danke
dass du auch heute für ein kurzes update
zur verfügung steht ist wie ist die lage
vor ort
janina am sonntag sind wir acht wochen
also zwei monate hier mein team und ich
verdiene jorgos montag ist der fotograf
und ich als reporter aber das was wir in
den letzten drei tagen gesehen haben in
butter das hat wirklich noch einmal
alles übertroffen an dramatik an tragik
an toth den wir schon in den wochen
zuvor gesehen haben dort über die straße
zu laufen menschen zu sehen die gerade
kartoffeln geholt haben und dann fahrrad
gefahren sind und dann erschossen wurden
menschen zu sehen die mit
verbundenen händen auf dem rücken
erschossen wurden menschen zu sehen in
einem auto ein teenager mit seinem vater
wo sportmedaille in diesem wagen laden
erschossen ein rentnerehepaar hundert
meter weiter dort auf diesem verlassenen
feldweg wo wir sie zufällig entdeckt
haben erschossen ich glaube es ganz
wichtig dass wir weiter über butscher
sprechen dass diese bilder gezeigt
werden dass wir bei bild diese bilder
zeigen und auch alle anderen medien
diese bilder zeigen denn das was dort
passiert das sind klare kriegsverbrechen
und egal was sehr gelacht auch dort sagt
egal wie viele lügende kreml dort
verbreitet ich kann immer nur wieder
sagen wir haben es mit unseren eigenen
augen gesehen und wenn man dort aus
butter kommt in butter gibt es kein
handynetz da hat jetzt elon musk gerade
eins seiner satellite hingeschickt aber
das funktioniert nur in einem engen
radius also normalerweise hat man dort
handynetz auch strom und wasser
funktioniert nicht wenn man dort raus
fährt und das ist bei mir gestern
gewesen dann springt das handy wieder an
nachrichten gehen und ich sehe eine
nachricht was sehr gelacht sagt dass die
ukraine das gemacht hätten oder die
briten oder wer auch immer dann ist man
als reporter fassungslos wenn man gerade
vor 15 minuten die leichen dort selbst
gesehen hat weil wir werden jetzt gleich
erstmal vielen herzlichen dank für ein
update und natürlich auch für seinen
unglaublichen einsatz wenngleich über
ein thema wir sprechen susanne gaschke
wird das vorstellen von der welt und
zwar toxische männlichkeit die ja
eigentlich auch dir vorgeworfen wurde
wegen dem wie du angezogen bist an der
front wirst du diese debatte in
deutschland wahrgenommen bevor wir sie
gleich am tisch debattieren
ich habe viele debatten der letzten zwei
monate als völlig absurd gesehen viele
konnte ich mir gar nicht zu gemüte
führen weil wir keine zeit hatten weil
wir eben hier berichtet haben aber man
merkt dann schon in was für einem ich
will ich sagen hätten aber wohlstands
satten land wie in deutschland leben das
wir uns bestimmte debatten leisten
können wenn es hier einfach nur um eines
geht um leben oder tod
bei vielen herzlichen dank dass doch
heute abend uns wieder informiert hass
und wir hören uns dann morgen abend
wieder dankeschön und
dazu kommen wir dann susanne zu dem
thema mit den toxischen männlichkeit ist
natürlich kein einfacher übergang jetzt
nach mehr als bewegenden worten ich
finde der noch wichtig dass wir das
thema debattieren aber er hat natürlich
recht es geht um leben und tod und zwar
leben und tod für die ukraine und man
fühlt sich schon manchmal
also wirklich erschüttert über was wir
hier schon banalitäten verhandeln und
insofern ist natürlich auch
eigenartig mir ist halt nur aufgefallen
in den vergangenen tagen das hat mich
also zunehmend irritiert und wir müssen
ja auch damit umgehen also näher wie wir
nicht damit umgehen können
offensichtlich dass wir eine eine eine
unerträgliche unerträgliche situation
mit ansehen müssen und offenbar nichts
tun können darüber können wir ja
vielleicht auch noch reden ja warum das
so schwer ist ich glaube der bauch bei
jedem sagt dann muss die nato jetzt rein
und der kopf sagt aber das gibt einen
atomkrieg in europa jedenfalls sehr
wahrscheinlich und deswegen geht es
nicht aber das ist ja das zerreißt man
ja das herz insofern ist es ist es etwas
abwegig aber die diskussion wird hier
trotzdem geführt und das finde ich so
ihre also eine spiegel kollegin eine
kolumnistin schreibt also ernsthaft über
den mutigen tapferen präsidenten
selensky dass der so im westen verehrt
wäre wäre das sei ja also irgendwie ein
schlimmer hinweis dass man jetzt
toxische männlichkeit also doch wieder
gut fände und eigentlich sollte man doch
auch angst zeigen können und und ich
glaube weinen können oder so ich weiß
jetzt nicht dass das weiß nicht ob sie
wörtlich geschrieben hat aber allein der
gedanke diese beiden dinge in verbindung
zu bringen und dann ist eben ja auch bei
uns hat leider leider auch von kollegen
des öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks
wieder vorgeworfen worden also mit
seiner art von berichterstattung also
nah dran am krieg ist würde er sozusagen
eine toxische männlichen männer bewegen
der weste und wahrscheinlich ja ich also
die mandate hat ja da selber nicht
erschossen wird und das macht einen
natürlich in einer einer unglaublichen
weise fassungslos wenn man davon
toxischer männlichkeit reden kann dann
ja wohl bei den russischen soldaten die
zivilbevölkerung hinrichten und die
vergewaltigung gegen frauen als
kriegswaffe einsetzen was sozusagen ein
gut erforscht ist mittel ist also das
haben dass männer armin immer getan das
ist fürchterlich und das muss man
kritisieren und nichts anderes und mir
ist einfach aufgefallen an an diesem
beispiel noch mal in was für einem
furchtbaren zustand der die diskussion
über die feministische debatte bei uns
über die frauenbewegung bei uns
eigentlich ist also das war doch mal
eine vernünftige veranstaltung die
gesagt hat so also frauen müssen in der
gesellschaft doch alles können und
dürfen und werden können was männer auch
können und dabei darf ihm nichts im weg
stehen und selbstverständlich müssen wir
alle uns wehren gegen sexuelle übergriff
ich kein oder gewalt in konkreter form
aber inzwischen sind wir doch bei einem
generalverdacht also gegen den alten
weißen bösen mann und dabei fällt denen
dann ihre weise sie lenski ein und nicht
putin ist also vollkommen irre
sozusagen den wir bekämpfen müssen der
sozusagen apriori schuldig ist da kommt
es auf den konkreten fall gar nicht an
und das ist natürlich ein machtkampf den
wir da haben und da sind also
verschiedene identitäts politische
gruppierungen hoch engagiert die die
sehen für sich einfach eine chance boden
gutzumachen und und jede opfergruppe hat
sozusagen also einfach ganz konkrete
macht und karriere ansprüche die größte
opfergruppe sind nach dieser lesart ich
teile die ausdrücklich nicht und viele
frauen teil den ich natürlich nach wie
vor die frauen und das endet dann
irgendwann damit also dass nicht etwa
die quote also ein unterstützungs
mitteln doch ist wo die männer das aktiv
verhindern dass eine tolle frau irgendwo
hinkommt sondern wirklich so eine ist
doch alles egal haltung herrscht wir
wurden jahrhundertelang unterdrückt
jetzt steht uns alles zu kompetenz
spielt keine rolle mehr ich kann jeden
job machen und das erleben wir leider so
ein bisschen wollen wir uns auch die
proporz besetzung mancher ministerien
ansehen
das war vielen einer die sind trotzdem
hat alles zusammen gepasst dass es
selten aber ich finde auch alleine dass
der feminismus oder die feministische
debatte die auch mir zum teil zu
überhitzt geführt wird das thema
aufgreifen der ukraine krieg also den
krieg gegen die ukraine und dann das in
dem fall unser kollege paul ronzheimer
weil er sie ich fand das völlig bizarr
diesen bericht ich hab mir gesagt was
soll denn paul ronzheimer tun damit er
nicht männlich rüberkommt also wer mit
dem karlsruher vorschlag hast du den
gelesen der beste vorschlag war für
solltest du im lastenfahrrad mit rosa
birkenstocks und wilhelm und wirken
stocks durch den krieg oder vielleicht
sowie neu sind diese stücke schreiben
über die toxisch männlichkeit selber in
den krieg als kriegsreporter ziehen die
frauen das ist ja auch möglich man kann
ja auch als frau kriegsreporter eine so
erfolgreiche kollegin ist übrigens vor
ort im zdf katrin eigendorf das jetzt
auch toxische männlichkeit machten
journalismus
wie weit ist die debatte dahin
abzudriften patricia also ich zu mir
total schwer mit diesem erstmal begriff
toxisch ich glaube den verwenden wir
jetzt nur noch also als eine schlechte
beziehung bist du unglücklich toxische
beziehung läuft im job schlecht er ist
auch eine toxische arbeitsplatz also
irgendwie ist alles irgendwie toxisch
geworden das scheint das modewort
überhaupt zu sein alles ist toxisch
deswegen lass uns das einfach schon mal
raus streichen toxisch und dann geht es
um männlichkeit und dann geht es um die
frage was ist männlichkeit was darf
wendigkeit und offenbar gibt es
bestrebungen und das finde ich seltsam
und ich würde mich selbst sogar als
feministin bezeichnen ich finde es aber
befremdlich wenn männlichkeit als sich
oder das was wir bisher als männlich
empfunden haben plötzlich und acta
gelegt werden muss um zu beweisen dass
man feminismus unterstützt und das
verschwimmt mir zu sehr ich verstehe
nicht warum
alte attribute ausgedient haben die wir
als männliche sehen weil wir sie uns
nicht mehr erlauben dürfen und ich
befürchte auch da wir uns dann als team
verlieren und zwar als team mann frau
als team die gemeinsam sagen wir wollen
auch dinge in unserer gesellschaft
verändern das ist völlig überfällig das
ist uns allen klar da müssen wir dinge
verändern ich möchte mehr männer in
elternzeit ich möchte mehr frauen in
chefetagen das möchte ich alles sehen
aber bitte lasst uns aufhören das so zu
verscherbeln dass man es am ende nicht
mehr versteht dass selbst ich als
unterstützerin dieser sache denke
vielleicht ist es manchmal gut einfach
ruhig zu sein von offenbar ich verwende
eine falsche vokabel und so man hat
irgendwann das gefühl man kann sich nur
noch in die nesseln setzen und ich
glaube das ist der sache die ich
unterstütze einfach nicht dienlich jetzt
ist es schwer sich als mann zu äußern
diese klinik dieser talk so schnell
wandeln möchte ich fast sagen aber ganz
ernsthaft und das war ja auch von
susanne gaschke gesagt wenn man paul
vorhersieht aus dem gebiet und da auch
seine seine reportagen ja über den
letzten 42 tage gesehen hat da muss man
sagen über welches thema reden wir
eigentlich gibt es einen präsidenten ob
der jetzt ein mann oder eine frau ist
weiß oder schwarz kurze haare lange
haare er stellt sich hin und will sein
land beschützen und zwar oder
verteidigen gegen ein aggressor gibt im
tierreich genug beispiele beispielsweise
von frauen also von von weiblichen
tieren die sich auch für ihre jungen
stellen das machen übrigens mütter auch
wenn ihre kinder angegriffen werden
stellen die sich in st da darfst du aber
ich darf nicht ganz normaler reflex dem
schiebt man immer den männern zu
komischerweise frauen können sich doch
genauso gut verteidigen und machen das
auch also wo ist das problem ist ein
präsident sagte ich und jetzt trägt er
auch noch ein t shirt also ist in
kampfmontur ich verteidige mit allem was
ich habe mein land schlafe drei bis vier
stunden wenn überhaupt die nacht und tue
alles damit mein land meine leute meine
männer frauen und die kinder die erleben
alle hoffentlich bald wieder in freiheit
leben können das doch irre und
vielleicht am rande sei mir eine
bemerkung nur erlaubt weil ich das eine
sehr spannende ausführung fand von
susanne gaschke diese diese gewisse mir
steht das gewisse mir steht alles zu
syndrom was ihr offenbar jetzt auch von
der feministischen bewegung immer
stärker nach vorne geschoben wird es
wird in den nächsten jahren einen
dramatischen fachkräftemangel geben wir
reden über sehr übers jahr 20 30 reden
von 5 millionen fachkräfte fehlen das
heißt da ist für männer und für frauen
das die gute nachricht des heutigen
abends genug platz auf spitzenpositionen
da brauchen wir keine toxischen kämpfe
sondern das regelt sich alles von selbst
wer gut ist kommt sowieso nach oben und
auch gar nicht so richtig gut ist wird
auch super job chancen haben also dass
die gute nachricht des heutigen abends
das war auch ein gewisses eigentor der
feministinnen der modernen für
ministerium die häufig solche eigentor
um machen die ukraine dort als beispiel
zu nähern diese art der kleidung wird in
der ukraine als zeichen der solidarität
mit den soldaten an der front auch von
frauen getragen eine gute freundin von
mir zum ukrainischen parlament die ist
auch zum kaffee zum frühstück genauso
angekommen weil das merkwürdig aussehen
würde in zeiten in denen ganz viele
soldaten an der front sterben sich als
mann mit krawatte schick zu machen sich
als frau mit bluse zurechtzumachen
dieses zeichen ist notwendig dieses
zeichen ist wichtig in der ukraine ist
das zielbild für die armee das
israelische modell bei dem auch frauen
genauso wie männer dienen sollen
übrigens auch mit einer wehrpflicht und
dieses zielbild ist gesellschaftlich
akzeptiert grad was will denn der
feminismus mehr erreichen als eine
solche art der gleichstellung bis in den
bereich hinein wo eben gekämpft wird bis
in den männlichsten beruf hinein den
beruf des soldaten
und ausgerechnet hier die ukraine zu
kritisieren ist ein dermaßen schlimmes
eigentor dass ich mich frage ob sich
jemand überhaupt mit der ukraine
beschäftigt hat aber es ist natürlich
genau
sozusagen ein ich weiß nicht einmal satt
oder fett gesagt hat es ist natürlich so
ein bisschen ein symptom also es geht
uns hier schon sehr sehr sehr gut und
wir haben unglaubliche demokratische
freiheiten die haben wir in corona finde
ich etwas wenig verteidigt grundrechte
und sozusagen jetzt die vorstellung dass
dein zeug einer völlig willkürlichen
kriegerischen aggressionen ausgesetzt
wird und sich verteidigt das ist
offenbar so weit von uns weg das
militärische ist so weit von uns weg
wenn das sieht man ja noch ein bisschen
auch an unserer verteidigungspolitik in
den ganzen letzten also zwei drei vier
legislaturperioden
wo also menschen immer frauen die dem
ganzen komplex sehr fern standen
fachlich die sich wirklich eigentlich
für andere sachen interessiert haben was
ihnen ja überhaupt nicht vorzuwerfen ist
aber so sagen dann also mit diesem
ganzen komplex also bundeswehr und
verteidigung konfrontiert waren dass wir
sehr lang wenig sind also ich meine es
war fast ein wunder dass scholz die
trendwende angekündigt hat und gesagt
hat wir liefern jetzt mal waffen wir
beharren jetzt nicht mehr auf unserem
gewalt ist keine lösung also wohl da die
menschen in den kellern sitzen oder
chancen auf der straße dient das war ja
immer es ist sehr schwer für ganz ganz
viel und vor allem für viele nicht böse
sein sozialdemokraten ist ist ganz ganz
schwer die müssen abstand nehmen von
einer illusion der sie und viele haben
gesagt es ist eine falsche version aber
sie haben an dieser person festgehalten
die sind traum geträumt frieden schaffen
ohne waffen es geht immer so weiter die
mauer ist weg und jetzt leben wir und
das geht mit russland so und die ist
eine illusion und ich gestehe auch jedem
zu das tut auch weh wenn ein traum
zerplatzt das ist auch schmerzhaft weil
man sich ja in gewisser weise extrem
selbst hinterfragen muss über 30 jahre
an die falsche sache geglaubt so und das
ist geplatzt aber man muss einfach
irgendwann dann sagen so und jetzt
müssen wir weiter und wir brauchen
glaube ich gerade deutschland viel mehr
verständnis dafür wie strategie auch
militärische strategie funktioniert und
wie kampf funktioniert so bitter das ist
ein schönes schloss play und damit
kommen wir zu die ja und du hast uns
heute ja auch ein zimmer gebracht und
ich bin sehr gespannt welches der
mainseite mitgebracht hast ich habe am
sonntag völlig zufällig den autokorso
einem langen großen autokorso mit
russischen flaggen hier mitten in berlin
gesehen
dutzende von autos
hupend fuhren durch die stadt ich habe
erstmal überhaupt nicht verstanden worum
es geht dann gab es ein paar schilder an
den autos man soll die russen nicht
hassen dieser autokorso wirkte auf mich
beängstigend ich komme selbst aus
russland muss ich dazu sagen erinnerte
mich auch an die langen reihen von
russischen militärfahrzeugen in der
ukraine von seiner ganzen aufmachung mit
dem aggressiven hupen und ich dachte mir
oh gott oh gott wie wird das wohl
ankommen wenn das hier erst mal gesehen
wird der nächste gedanke war bestimmt
wurde dass sie von russischen botschaft
organisiert denn niemand wird doch
wirklich an einem tag an dem wir die
kriegsverbrechen den user sehen einen
solchen autokorso organisieren ohne sich
zu überlegen wie das ankommt dann habe
ich mich damit beschäftigt wer das war
und es hat sich herausgestellt es ist
ein auto werkstatt unternehmer der das
ganze auf die beine stellte ich bin in
die geschlossene gruppe von diesen
telegramm gruppe von diesem auto kursen
reingegangen und habe recherchiert was
für menschen sind da was treibt sie an
glauben sie wirklich daran dass der
krieg in der ukraine eine gute sache ist
wollten die uns etwa das hier zeigen ich
habe dort eine umfrage gemacht und in
dieser umfrage die ist auf russisch
durchgeführt habe ich eben gefragt
unterstützt hier den krieg oder
unterstützt die nicht ich hab sogar
gefragt unterstützt diese
spezialoperation um niemanden in eine
ecke zu drängen nur 18 prozent haben
sich als unterstützer dieses krieges
geoutet 70 prozent haben gesagt ich bin
gegen diesen krieg das ist eine
aggression russlands ein überraschendes
ergebnis für mich und auch ein ganz
wichtiges ergebnis die mehrheit der
russen in deutschland und auch selbst
bei diesen autokorso unterstützt nicht
diesen krieg und wer die russen als
unterstützer von diesem krieg dich hier
mit uns in unserem land leben hin stellt
der spiel den ball in die hände viele
die ich hier dabei waren haben gar nicht
verstanden wo sie da mitmachen und wie
das wirkt und deshalb appelliere ich nur
dafür nicht alle russen in deutschland
als unterstützer von diesem krieg
abzustempeln
ich hätte hier eine frage die erste
frage ist es heißt ja immer so schön
nicht wissen hat schützt nicht dem
entsprechen wenn man das natürlich
mitgemacht hat und mitgetragen hat dann
kann man jetzt nicht sagen wann es pro
ukraine
die zweite frage die ich habe wenn das
stimmt und ich hoffe sehr dass es stimmt
dass die mehrheit der russen für die
befreiung der ukraine sind und dass sie
also dafür sind dass putin weggehauen
wird und dass der aggressor
zurückweichen muss warum sehe ich dann
keine präklinischen aufmärsche von
russen in deutschland warum gibt es
diese demonstration nicht warum zeigt
man es nicht nach außen wir stehen
hinter der ukraine
die frage muss man glaube ich an die
kollegen von den medien richten gerade
am freitag war hier in berlin eine
demonstration die von bussen organisiert
vor der russischen botschaft von
organisationen west nahe heißt frühling
stattgefunden hat davon habe ich nichts
gesehen ich habe jetzt diesen autokorso
auf seite eins vieler zeitungen gesehen
auch dieser bericht ist also auch an die
medienleute auch diejenigen mal sichtbar
zu machen auch mal an den berliner
hauptbahnhof zu gehen und die helfer die
dort ein russisches also als russisch
sprach ich eindeutig ausgewiesen sind
mal zu fragen wo kommst du eigentlich
her und ganz viele werden sagen ich
komme aus russland oder ich komme als
gönner aus belarus einem freund von mir
hat mir heute erzählt eine gute freundin
von ihm kommt aus belarus ein flüchtling
haben sie gefragt wo sie herkommt sie
sagte aus belarus daraufhin hat er sie
angespuckt sie ist er als helferin im
einsatz aber das ist auch bei jemandem
der ist kriegsopfer nach deutschland
kommt den krieg in fluren das
nachvollziehbar bloß wir sollten den
fehler nicht machen schauen wir uns doch
mal wirklich an wie viele russen
russlanddeutsche und andere abends an
diesen bahnhöfen stehen lebensmittel
verteilen
hilfstransport organisieren
hilfstransporte fahren tage lang ohne
schlaf ganz ganz viele davon sind russen
es ging ja auch viele menschen aus
russland also sozusagen vor denen immer
weniger demokratisch und rechtsstaatlich
werden den verhältnissen und dem und dem
staatsterror dort also auch die werden
natürlich hier in der gesellschaft dann
irgendwie aufgenommen und dürfen auf gar
keinen fall also in mithaftung genommen
werden und natürlich gibt es immer eine
gefahr dass man in einer ohnehin
komplexen situation auf einfache
feindbilder reduziert trotzdem würde
mich mal interessieren weil sie haben
sie denn ist denn in dieser telegramm
gruppe danach mal diskutiert worden wie
das gewirkt hat und ob das so eine
glückliche idee war oder dass leute
gesagt haben das hätten wir vielleicht
lieber bleiben lassen
also ich nehme auch den vorwurf an die
medien sofort an ich weiß es schlicht
nicht also ob wir genug gucken wo russen
sich jetzt sozusagen solidarisieren mit
den ukrainern das nehme ich jetzt
einfach mal mit aber diese sache hat ja
nun stattgefunden und und der zeitpunkt
war denkbar ungünstig und die wirkung
leider auch also ist da ist gab es
danach klappt dann die selbstkritik hält
sich noch in grenzen die wortführer dort
sind kriegsbefürworter ohne ist
großartig an die große glocke zu hängen
und sich dazu zu bekennen initiatoren
sind ganz klar hinter putz ihn nicht die
nummer eins der hält sich zurück aber so
ein bisschen die führungsgruppe dahinter
sind wirklich ganz viele hinter putin
und diese 18 prozent die für diese
spezialoperation sich bekannt haben sind
sehr lautstark ich glaube dass
nachdenken fängt jetzt erst dann es gibt
eine gegen gruppe von ukrainern
organisiert bei telegramm wo jedes
einzelne auto abfotografiert mit
kennzeichen mit einem aufruf das auto zu
beschädigen die person anzugreifen
eingestellt wurde erst jetzt wird
langsam verstanden welches ausmaß man
eigentlich an abneigung erreicht hat mit
einer demonstration deren ziel war
diskriminierung zu vermeiden genau das
hat man jetzt geschafft genau das
gegenteil von dem was man eigentlich
wollte sich ließen die serben die reden
ja
wirklich nicht sichtbar und ich glaube
ich meine das war 900 personen die sich
dort getroffen haben 400 autos ich weiß
auch die demonstration ist sie
angesprochen haben die russische die die
solidarität mit der ukraine gezeigt wenn
sie dann noch mal ein ordner wie viele
das war und dass wir da auch darüber
berichten das möchte ich nicht auf mir
sitzen lassen aber für das verständnis
pochen das was natürlich auch ab einer
gewissen größe dann oft auch der fall
ist das war da besonders auffällig dass
900 menschen mitgemacht haben ich glaube
man kann sich nicht davor verstecken
dass man nicht wusste was dort passiert
selbst wenn man sagt man möchte gegen
oder für mehr verständnis oder man
möchte auch davor warnen dass
kein hass geschürt wird jetzt zwischen
uns ein ich glaube ich muss man sich
schon fragen ob das ein guter zeitpunkt
ist mit großen russischen fahnen jetzt
quer durch berlin hupend am hauptbahnhof
vorbei zu fahren an einem tag und grauen
grauenvolle bilder aus butter 1 wir das
schleichende findet dieser verantwortung
kann sich kein mensch der dort mit
gefahren ziehen
kann ich leider auch so nicht gelten
lassen das war der schlechteste
zeitpunkt dennoch blieb das erklärte
ziel dieser demonstration und der die
offizielle anmeldung eben eine
demonstration gegen diskriminierung und
wenn man das erreichen wollte hat man
genau das gegenteil erreicht deshalb
kann ich wirklich auch an eigentlich
muslim russlands regierung unter premier
und russland oder war das eine
demonstration gegen diskriminierung
deutschland weil mein eindruck ist
eigentlich dass wir es in russland mit
einem land zu tun haben das extrem hart
diskriminiert seine eigene bevölkerung
das thema diskriminierung ist meiner
erkenntnis nach in deutschland
eigentlich
fehlen mir ist nicht bekannt dass
auch jemand der ein russe ist und hier
eine russische flagge hoch hält
beispielsweise ins gefängnis kommt das
passiert nicht alle tage also auch da
glaube ich ist es bemerkenswert dass
sich russen in deutschland auf die
straße stellen und sagen wir kämpfen
hier gegen diskriminierung
mein eindruck ist dass es in ihrem
eigenen heimatland der freiheit david
schwerst diskriminiert da wird gefoltert
aber das passiert aber mich hat auch ein
bisschen irritiert also der umgang
wieder mal des berliner senats mit
dieser geschichte denn da war er dann
also sehr stark sehr schnell also von
meinungsfreiheit sei das höchste gut und
so weiter das finde ich auch absolut
also man kann jedem 17 sekunden seien
derzeit wenig dazu gebannt zugehört wir
müssen leider hier abbrechen schönen
abend ihnen noch spannendes und
spannendes thema bis morgen abend dann
wieder hier schönen abend noch
[Musik]